[Música]
el 22 de marzo es el Día Mundial del
agua en el marco de esa conmemoración en
France 24 y en el programa El Debate
quisimos analizar alguna realidad o
coyuntura que estuviera relacionada con
este tema y que tuviera lugar en algún
Rincón de nuestro planeta por supuesto
esto nos lleva Entonces hasta Japón en
donde hace ya varios meses las
autoridades de ese país aprobaron la
liberación de agobas residuales de la
planta nuclear de fukushima daishi esta
planta resultó seriamente afectada
recordemos el 11 de marzo del 2011
cuando un fuerte terremoto de
9,0 grados y un posterior tsunami
sacudió a Japón y afectó esta planta y
por eso pues el mundo entero estaba en
vilo por lo que podría suceder en esta
central nuclear posteriormente muchos
años después las autoridades de Japón
anunciaron que verterán a partir de la
primavera del 2023 primavera en el
hemisferio norte van a verter al mar más
de un millón de toneladas de agua
contaminada procedente de esta central
nuclear las aguas ya han sido tratadas
presentan niveles de radioactividad que
están dentro de los niveles que estipula
la ley japonesa y también las leyes
Internacionales La oea afirmó que la
medida es completamente segura pero hay
preocupación entre Los Pescadores
locales entre los ciudadanos y entre los
países vecinos y por supuesto en la
comunidad internacional hoy en el debate
de France 24 analizamos este plan que
tiene Japón de invertir esta agua
residual de la central nuclear de
fukushima a aguas del océano Pacífico
Qué consecuencias tiene esto para el
medio ambiente lo vamos a ver en detalle
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a Carmen grau Vila ella es
periodista e investigadora adjunta de la
universidad bacera ella se encuentra en
la ciudad de Tokio en Japón allí en la
capital japonesa y desde Madrid se
conecta a esta conversación Florentino
rodao él es catedrático de la
Universidad complutense de Madrid
también es autor del libro La del paño
es vulnerable Japón desde
1945 nuestros televidentes ustedes ya lo
saben hacen parte de este debate pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales en Twitter
Facebook e Instagram no se encuentran
como arroba
franz24_s la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 a mí
en Twitter me encuentran como arroba
santilogo no olviden también que todos
los contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Carmen en la ciudad de Tokio en Japón
Carmen Gracias por estar con nosotros en
el debate y comienzo preguntándole por
su percepción sobre lo que significa
esta medida si es adecuada si es un
riesgo para el medio ambiente Qué
significa esta decisión que ha tomado
Japón en cuanto a esta agua residual de
la planta de fukushima
bueno en primer lugar Muchas gracias por
la invitación buenas noches para ustedes
bien respondiendo a su pregunta es un
tema muy complejo Que en Japón lleva
tratando de solucionar desde el 2011 con
una serie de medidas que han ido
variando a lo largo del tiempo hasta
llegar a la conclusión gubernamental y
empresarial de la empresa que gestiona
la central la empresa tepco de que ya no
tenían espacio suficiente de acuerdo a
su argumentación para
seguir realizando los trabajos de
desmantelamiento y descontaminación de
las aguas contaminadas por tanto debido
a este argumento de espacio de relativo
espacio limitado han pasado desde el
2001 a lanzar este esta solución no para
verter el agua al Pacífico
y pasó ahora a saludar a Florentino en
la ciudad de Madrid Gracias por estar
con nosotros Florentino su opinión sobre
esta decisión que han tomado las
autoridades japonesas en torno a este
tema Gracias por estar con nosotros
bienvenido
bien Efectivamente es muy complicada y
hay que decir también que cuando hubo
problemas precisamente a raíz de la
explosión que hubo en fukushima en esos
momentos también Se tiró hay que decir
que Japón es muy afortunado por todo el
espacio de agua que tiene y
efectivamente tiró tiró algo de
bastantes aguas aguas
contaminadas digamos entonces claro
obviamente se ha llenado y yo la verdad
no veo otra solución pero claro tampoco
es una buena solución pero es que no hay
otras
Carmen este procedimiento es un
procedimiento
habitual en los funcionamientos de las
centrales nucleares llega un momento en
que la capacidad de almacenamiento de
estas aguas residuales a lo largo de
tantos años de funcionamiento recordemos
que esta planta tiene unos reactores que
vienen funcionando desde la década del
70 más o menos otros fueron activados en
la década del 80 Ya llevan muchos años
funcionando esto es normal o esto es
simplemente porque fukushima fue víctima
de este tsunami de este terremoto bueno
la explosión que luego tuvo posterior
este desastre natural pues agravó la
situación pero es simplemente porque se
está presentando a raíz de este desastre
natural o es un procedimiento normal
efectivamente la central de fukushima se
construyó en los años 70 en el norte de
una región al norte de Tokio que está
como a 270 kilómetros de la capital
japonesa y ha sido una fuente importante
en el sector económico de la región pero
no hay que olvidar que esta región
además es una región pesquera por lo
tanto la industria pesquera se ha visto
muy afectada desde el 2011 desde el
accidente y
la respondiendo a su pregunta la
organización internacional de energía
atómica la oea junto con el gobierno
japonés uno de los argumentos que que
dan para explicar este proyecto es que
la energía nuclear Ya de por sí produce
residuos que son lanzados o vertidos al
mar no solo por Japón sino por todas las
potencias nucleares del mundo entre
ellas también por supuesto Estados
Unidos y otros países como Francia china
no que son los principales
nucleares en la actualidad entonces bien
el problema es que que lo que van a
realizar Los japoneses es algo que no se
ha hecho hasta hasta la actualidad no
después de un accidente nuclear todo el
proceso desmantelamiento y todos los
residuos que se han creado entre ellos
la el agua altamente contaminada van a
ser vertidos y aquí pues hay una gran
reacción ciudadana hay mucho el sector
pesquero está totalmente en contra de
este vertido porque bien hay dos
factores uno que es que han sido muy
afectados desde el 2011 y han tardado
muchos años en recuperarse todavía no se
han recuperado totalmente los productos
de fukushima sobre todo los pesqueros y
los agrícolas han sido bueno Están
estigmatizados y bien pues eso produce
cierta reticencia al proyecto
gubernamental Carmen usted ya tocó un
tema importante y es la perspectiva que
hay política en torno a este tema y como
lo está viviendo la sociedad japonesa y
cómo lo viven los luga reños voy a
profundizar en ese tema más adelante
dejémoslo sobre la mesa Quiero
preguntarle a Florentino sobre el riesgo
que esto implica Carmen decía que en
este tipo de Procedimientos si bien lo
avalan como un procedimiento seguro las
aguas ya han pasado por un tratamiento y
tienen unos niveles de contaminación
aceptables es algo que no se ha hecho
anteriormente es un riesgo calculado Qué
es lo que está en riesgo acá
Mira Perdona se puede decir que está muy
calculado yo sí te puedo decir que
estuve en mururo a el este verano Y
desde luego allí todavía no se puede
tomar pescado contaminado por las
explosiones nucleares de los 80 el tema
nuclear es muy muy complicado lleva
mucho tiempo para aclararlo y es normal
que haya temores de la población Es muy
normal es lo que podemos decir ahora y
cuál es el riesgo entonces que hay Hay
riesgo para o sea esto podría acabar
como dice Carmen con esa industria
pesquera De esta zona del Japón del
Norte del archipiélago que vive
netamente de del mar Esto entonces ha
obligado a que el gobierno japonés tenga
que implementar algún plan adicional
para estos habitantes que vende la pesca
que se está moviendo allí Dentro de este
riesgo calculado Carmen
bueno el gobierno japonés ha invertido
en gentes cantidades de dinero de
millones de yenes desde el 2011 para
subvencionar a Los Pescadores afectados
por no solamente por la central de
fukushima pero sobre todo también Los
afectados por el Tsunami que perdieron
sus medios de vida y han hecho una
reconstrucción ingente donde han hecho
grandes avances y la pesca en algunos
lugares ha vuelto a niveles anteriores
al 2011 con lo cual para la para Los
japoneses esto un logro pero en el caso
de fukushima todavía lidian con Pues que
por ejemplo dentro de Japón todavía hay
reticencias respecto a estos productos
que vienen de la región y no solamente
dentro de Japón lo que más preocupa a
Los pescadores de la zona que
en algunas ocasiones he podido consultar
es los vetos fuera de Japón no aunque se
han ido alcanzando algunos vetos desde
los últimos años por ejemplo en 2021 el
apoyo de Estados Unidos ha sido una gran
avance Taiwán también desde el año
pasado
ha levantado algunos vetos todavía hay
naciones como Corea del Sur o china que
mantienen fuertes vetos para para los
productos de la región pero digamos que
no solamente se muestran disconformes
Los pescadores de
es importante remarcar que no solamente
Los pescadores de fukushima
los representantes nacionales de Los
pescadores de Nacionales también han
mostrado su rechazo porque creen que
puede perjudicar a la pesca japonesa en
general en líneas generales es un país
que tiene una industria de pescado muy
sólida y también es un producto muy
consumido allí eso afectaría no
solamente las exportaciones y el
prestigio que tiene Japón en este tipo
de productos a nivel mundial sino
también que afectaría el consumo interno
en caso de que esto empiece a desatar
algún tipo de problemas que eso pues
todavía está por por verse a futuro
Florentino retomo la comunicación con
usted para preguntarle cómo entender que
no haya preocupación a nivel
internacional por este tipo de medidas
uno no ve a países internacionales a
nivel internacional haciendo denuncias o
pidiéndole a Japón información sobre
esto si ha habido algunos
pronunciamientos por parte de Corea por
parte de China por parte de Taiwán pero
no hay una opinión internacional sobre
este tema a Japón lo están dejando
actuar de manera libre y nadie le está
consultando el riesgo que esto puede
implicar a gran escala
Perdone que que le haga una visión
general y creo que hay que compararlo
con con el caso de bueno de Ucrania
precisamente la la explosión nuclear que
iba allí no decir igual que la zona esta
no me sale ahora la explosión nuclear en
igual que esa zona está totalmente
abandonada Los japoneses han hecho un
gran esfuerzo precisamente por recuperar
esta historia eso es muy admirable por
parte de Japón de un territorio que no
se podía dejar abandonar no como han
como ha ocurrido en xenón últimamente no
Entonces ahí sí que hay que reconocerlo
ahora bien obviamente lo que no se puede
tampoco es evitar todas las suspicacias
y no solamente podemos hablar de los
temores que bueno del rechazo digamos a
comprar productos de la región y de
varias regiones de Japón por parte de
China y Corea y de otros territorios
sino también No nos olvidemos también
por parte de los propios japoneses
teniendo constancia o Sabiendo de la
posibilidad
aunque no haya casos claros de que haya
contaminación de los productos no
solamente de los marítimos sino también
de lo que se está cultivando en esta
región entonces claro ahí choca mucho el
problema japonés No sé si te acuerdas
hace unos años también una pues una
anécdota no pero Japón intentó hacer una
carrera de motos e internacional
precisamente por esa zona Me parece que
en la zona de sendai y hubo muchos
autores muchos motoristas que no
quisieron no me acuerdo uno que decirse
no lo hago yo por mí sino por mis hijos
no los temores de la gente eso son
imposibles imposibles digamos de quitar
más que de una forma muy suave después
del accidente de fukushima repito es muy
admirable lo que ha hecho el gobierno
japonés de recuperar esta esta región
Pero también es muy comprensible por
parte la gente japoneses por supuesto
también por parte de los temores que se
están teniendo a estas a esta a este a
esta contaminación nuclear eso es una
ecuación muy muy difícil en la cual esto
que se está hablando ahora se lleva
hablando muchos años de la cuestión de
tirar hay mucho problema de opinión
pública evidentemente pero hace falta
mucho tiempo para que la gente de alguna
forma recupere esa
Florentino en ese en ese orden de ideas
y con lo que usted explica y con esta
recuperación admirable que ha hecho
Japón las autoridades de este país para
recuperar esta zona del país entendiendo
también que Japón es un país que carece
de espacio y cada milímetro de tierra
que pierden es vital para ellos es
fundamental
en ese orden de ideas sigue habiendo un
desconocimiento por parte de la sociedad
a nivel mundial en torno a los temas
nucleares a raíz de lo de chernóbil y de
todas estas series que hemos visto en
las diferentes plataformas que muestran
como algo catastrófico y el final de los
tiempos y del mundo y de la humanidad
entera
Es simplemente por esta este bombardeo
de desinformación que tenemos la energía
nuclear es una energía segura sigue
siendo una energía rentable y buena y y
que puede seguir siendo una fuente de
energía para los países que están un
poco más relegados y retrasados en su
proceso de
de cambio de matriz energética
Florentino
vamos a ver yo me acuerdo hace unos años
el economist no un una revista bastante
seria me acuerdo que la conclusión
después de analizar en la cuestión de la
energía nuclear es que efectivamente
podía ser segura la energía nuclear pero
con un gasto tan inmenso que no era
factible lo que se está diciendo ahora
por parte de las de la energía nuclear
de las empresas es que hablan de las
centrales de cuarta generación que ya
sería mucho más seguras y ahí lo que
pasa pues es factible es factible no
pero hasta qué punto podemos fiarnos de
unas empresas de las cuales como hemos
sabido en el caso de por ejemplo en aquí
Bueno pues eso ha habido un fallo ha
habido fallos humanos evidentes Hasta
qué punto se pueden editar en otros
casos claro responder eso de Hasta qué
puntos factible desde luego fíjate que
ahora precisamente con la cuestión de
Rusia de los problemas de la energía
hay países que siguen muy recientes en
Europa todavía incluso la energía
nuclear por parte de Francia ha tenido
problemas ahora se están recuperando no
Incluso se la llevó a declarar de alguna
forma factible como permitir inversiones
no
no lo sé hoja Ojalá lo pudiéramos saber
Pero hay un Perdón ahí pero hay una
tendencia a desconfiar del nuevo
argumento de las de las cuartas de las
centrales de cuarta generación
precisamente Sabiendo Cómo han sido las
terceras no Y desde luego una energía
nuclear que aparte de eso es limpia y es
barata y es muy efectiva sería muy
positivo pero hasta qué punto nos claro
y ese es mi punto se lo preguntó también
a Carmen A ver cuál es su punto su punto
de vista que tal vez lo que pasa acá es
que hay mucha desinformación la sociedad
desconoce muchas bondades de la energía
nuclear y también
satanizado un poco a raíz del accidente
de chernóbil y del accidente de
fukushima se ha Pues desprestigiado
digamos
las bondades de la energía nuclear
Carmen qué piensa usted Bueno aquí me
gustaría ponerles como ejemplo lo que me
dijo uno de los japoneses afectados que
conocí hace poco en minamisoma una de
las ciudades afectadas por la radiación
dentro de los 20 kilómetros
cercanos a la central esta persona
estuvo desde el 2011 hasta el 2017
evacuada en otra región de Japón porque
no se podía vivir donde donde tenía su
hogar y regresó en 2017 debido a los
trabajos de descontaminación al ser una
zona con menos radiación que otras han
podido regresar Es una persona mayor y
al regresar cuando lo entreviste yo le
preguntaba No o sea cuál es su opinión
ahora sobre la energía nuclear debido a
que Japón Además está variando su su
política y ahora está apostando un poco
más por volver a la energía nuclear a
pesar de que tiene activos 10 reactores
en el país de los 54 que tenía no hace
hace más de 10 años entonces esta
persona me decía Mira yo no te puedo
contestar si estoy A favor o estoy en
contra y es un poco curioso no siendo
que una persona tan afectada Esto sí sí
lo que te puedo decir es que hasta que
el público hasta que la gente no
cambiemos nuestro forma de pensar y en y
se introduzca la central no la energía
nuclear sino también el hecho de los
residuos nucleares no lo que me decía
Esta persona es no somos conscientes de
la cantidad de residuos nucleares que
genera esta esta energía y que van a
estar generaciones tras generaciones con
nosotros y que todavía no hemos
encontrado una forma de gestionar
entonces lo que él me quería decir es
que hasta que no cambiemos nuestro
modelo energético la energía nuclear va
a seguir siendo una realidad los
gobiernos van a apostar por ella porque
es una energía limpia y como ha dicho
Florentino no y es más económica que
otras Pero qué pasa con los residuos no
las consecuencias de esta de esta
energía que además va a tener un límite
Porque muchos países ya ya están
empezando a tener problemas con sus
cementerios nucleares no entonces pues
es una reflexión que me gustaría lanzar
compartir con ustedes que viene de una
de las personas afectadas Carmen
acertado ese comentario para entender un
poco la percepción que tienen los
japoneses sobre este caso particular
siendo ellos testigos de primera mano de
lo que sucedió en el año 2011 eso Carmen
en cuanto a una persona que estuvo ahí
que ha convivido con la central nuclear
a lo largo de los años que vivió el
accidente y la explosión
en su lo vivió allí en primera mano pero
que hay del resto de la sociedad
japonesa hay unidad en torno a la
continuidad de la del manejo de la
energía nuclear en Japón hay rechazo en
torno a esta medida que piensa la
sociedad japonesa porque es un motor
económico que no se puede dar el lujo de
apagarse o de desacelerar su motor
económico por el tamaño y lo robusta que
es la economía japonesa y que pues
claramente necesita estar activa y
necesita fuentes de energía pero allí
son escasas
Efectivamente es un sector económico muy
importante además es un lobby que
trabaja junto al gobierno no al actual
gobierno y bueno y a los anteriores
también y bueno en general la opinión
pública
hay dos Yo diría que hay dos tipos de
opinión pública en Japón gente que se
muestra muy de acuerdo con la energía
nuclear porque quizá está vinculada
económicamente con esta industria pero
luego hay una gran parte de opinión
pública es de japoneses de ciudadanos
que han sido muy reivindicativos Durante
los años 70-80 también por el debido a
la historia que tiene Japón con las
bombas atómicas no y las víctimas de
las bombas atómicas de Hiroshima y
nagasaki hay una gran parte de la
ciudadanía ha sido muy activa para
alertar a la población del peligro No
solamente la energía nuclear también de
la de las armas nu Entonces digamos que
todavía hay una gran parte de la
población que que se que reivindica que
en Japón debería de cambiar Este modelo
pero no no es que se hacían una minoría
es que Japón es un país que no no es tan
homogéneo no entonces uno cuando viaja a
las regiones por ejemplo cuando uno
viaja a la zona afectada de por la
central se encuentra a muchos ciudadanos
que están haciendo un gran esfuerzo por
regresar a sus hogares Y también por
monitorear lo que está ocurriendo en sus
en sus territorios es decir monitorean
al propio gobierno están haciendo
análisis del suelo viendo Cuáles son los
niveles radiación están haciendo una
serie de trabajo de apoyo y también de
vigilancia en su territorio Y esto es
algo que no es tan conocido no que no
suele salir tanto y que y que me
gustaría transmitir no que que hay una
parte de ciudadanía japonesa que está
haciendo un gran trabajo por por
alzar su voz no y
una veeduría ciudadana para constatar y
confirmar que se están haciendo los
trabajos de limpieza y descontaminación
adecuados Florentino viendo un poco la
historia de este tipo de situaciones y
accidentes nucleares a raíz de chernóbil
se empezó a cuestionar a nivel
internacional sobre si la energía
nuclear era la indicada para seguir
siendo una fuente energética confiable y
limpia luego viene el accidente de
fukushima cuando ya se estaba avanzando
en esa transición energética y digamos
que esto aceleró esa toma de decisiones
vimos el caso de Alemania que decidió
ponerle punto final a la energía nuclear
pero ahora el escenario es muy distinto
y la Guerra de Ucrania ha llevado a
países precisamente como Alemania tener
que encender otro tipo de
fuentes para poder abastecer de energía
a sus países estamos en este momento
dando pasos hacia adelante un poco más
pequeños o nos estamos devolviendo un
poco en esos avances que estábamos
haciendo en cuanto a la transición
energética nos cuesta hacer esa
transición energética usted qué piensa
si nos cuesta pero
Perdón yo quizás tengo el problema que
soy demasiado optimista pero lo hemos
hecho muy bien
hemos hecho viendo si si nos ponemos en
el 24 de febrero del año pasado que de
repente Putin nos cortaba todo no
olvidemos solamente eso sino que en el
caso España Por ejemplo Me parece que el
40% del gas no lo mandaban desde Argelia
y se nos estaba cancelando ya por
problemas de Marruecos etcétera nosotros
de repente hemos dejado de recibir el
40% de gas de Argelia en un año y nos
hemos recuperado y hemos hecho el boicot
A cómo se llamaba Putin etcétera y no
han subido los precios y estamos
haciendo una transición Perdón que lo
digo después de todas estas líos
relativamente buena relativamente buena
los precios podían haber subido mucho
más hemos tenido la suerte el buen
tiempo en Europa etcétera otra serie
cuestiones entonces la transición está
saliendo y yo creo que está saliendo
demasiado bien que es el lo decía hace
poco como que vamos a teníamos que
agradecer a Putin precisamente que con
todas las movidas que ha habido habla de
diez años que nos hemos adelantado en en
la descontaminación en avanzar en una
una nueva programa nuclear Perdón un
nuevo programa de energía medioambiental
etcétera no entonces Está avanzando
muchísimo por muchos lados todavía no lo
hemos visto España ya ha empezado a
tener momentos en los que es
autosuficiente Fíjate que por ejemplo
Alemania está habla muy bien de Alemania
y de hecho ha habido polémicas por
algunas obras de algunas minas de cardón
de Carbón que se han abierto pero
temporalmente en España también ha
habido una serie de centrales de Carbón
que se han abierto y está claro que es
temporalmente entonces realmente se está
haciendo muy bien Mira y de las cosas
que hemos estado hablando y está muy
bien lo que dice Carmen del apoyo de la
gente no del apoyo del control de la
gente hay que decir otra cosa
cuando fue el el triple desastre había
otra central nuclear que ahora no me
acuerdo del nombre que estaba más cerca
del epicentro del desastre y que apenas
tuvo daños en el caso de fukushima
sabéis bueno llevaban una década
intentando que aumentaran las que tenían
las las murallas de solamente 10 metros
se quería que se aumentaran y
precisamente el mes anterior habían
estado de pruebas si hubiera habido unas
unas murallas suficientemente altas no
habría pasado nada Y eso precisamente la
empresa estaba remoloneando Para no
gastar Bueno pues lo que hay que decir
igual que Teco que era una empresa muy
grande y que cuando habían revisiones se
lo revisaban ellos mismos y el estado no
tenía capacidad en el caso de esa otra
empresa nuclear que tenía una que tenía
una central nuclear pasando todas las
revisiones y haciéndolo bien esa empresa
solamente tuvo un pequeño incendio en
ese momento cuando él fue el maremoto y
de hecho esa misma noche la gente que en
casa fueron a a resguardarse a la a la
central nuclear con eso que te quiero
decir que también tiene que haber y es
crucial una labor por parte del Estado
de controlar todos los datos que dicen
las empresas quizás en el problema de
Teco era una empresa demasiado poderosa
para ser controlada por el estado frente
a la otra central nuclear de una empresa
pequeña que es así que estaba
monitoreada y que es así que funcionaba
de acuerdo Entonces ahí hay una labor
del estado que es crucial
informar y supervisar Carmen su opinión
sobre este tema sobre lo que dice
Florentino y sobre este tema que ponía
yo sobre la mesa de la transición
energética si fukushima y la guerra en
Ucrania lo están acelerando o lo están
poniendo un poco más lento su opinión
bueno como ha comentado Florentino estos
Yo diría que
desde el 2011 en Japón se han hecho
también grandes avances y el gobierno
japonés ha subvencionado
la energía por ejemplo solar en 10 años
el país se ha cubierto de placas solares
independientemente de
lo que podamos opinar de esto
muchas empresas extranjeras han llegado
a Japón para invertir entre ellas
españolas alemanas y ha habido una gran
expansión de este de este mercado
energético solar en Japón no
dicho esto como viene comentado al
principio de 54 rectores que tenía Japón
repartidos por todo el país después del
terremoto se suspendieron casi todos y
en 2022 había 10 operando y 21 de
comisionados que no hay planes de volver
a activar dicho esto también desde el
año pasado con el Primer Ministro
kishida y debido al contexto
internacional y la Guerra de Ucrania
Japón ha vuelto a decir que que apuesta
de nuevo por volver a aumentar
la producción de energía nuclear
Entonces está por ver un poco cuántos
reactores va a poner en marcha de nuevo
pero esa es su apuesta en la actualidad
Y esa puesta Carmen y el accidente y la
limpieza y descontaminación y esta
decisión de perder esta agua contaminada
al Pacífico le ha pasado en cierta forma
cuenta de cobro al gobierno japonés No
específicamente desde el primer ministro
kishida sino a lo que ha venido desde
antes
ha pasado cuenta de cobro los ciudadanos
le han pasado factura ha habido condena
al gobierno por este tipo de medidas o
por esta idea que usted nos Comenta de
apostarle nuevamente a la energía
nuclear en un momento de transición
energética
digamos que
el partido liberal democrático que es el
partido en el poder
lleva muchos años gestionando gobernando
Japón son más de 60 años más de seis
décadas
las decisiones que ha tomado aunque no
han sido muy populares
la sociedad japonesa tampoco se ha
mostrado tan crítica en el sentido de
manifestaciones sí que ha habido sí que
hay todavía por ejemplo podemos
encontrar a un grupo de
de ciudadanos en contra de la energía
nuclear y críticos con la gestión de
fukushima a las puertas del Ministerio
de economía uno puede ir ahora mismo al
centro de Tokio y se los va a encontrar
están día y noche desde hace más de 10
años apostados para que el gobierno siga
escuchándolos no pero quitando de esta
crítica ciudadana Pues de momento la
ciudadanía está la espera no esperando a
ver cómo se va a resolver
pero si todo apunta como lo como como
parece que está ocurriendo Pues de los
planes se van a llevar a cabo Sí están
aprobados Florentino Carmen vamos
llegando al bloque final de el programa
para ir cerrando quiero preguntarles que
allí en Japón se habla de algún plan
para esta central nuclear después de que
saquen toda esta agua contaminada que
esto no va a ser de un día para otros
todo va a ser un proceso escalonado va a
tomar varios meses incluso piensan que
puede extenderse Más allá del 2023 Qué
planes hay entonces para esta central La
idea es renovarla actualizarla
modernizarla adecuarla cerrarla por
completo Cuál va a ser el futuro de
fukushima daishi
Florentino
quería que hablara Carmen primero que
que es la que vive allí no perdona es
que si hay que decirlo que una Carmen
corrígeme que tú lo sabes mejor una
sentencia con lo cual los dirigentes
detecte o de la empresa que fue la
culpable han sido liberados y eso es una
pena eh Es una pena porque creo que algo
de culpa podían haber tenido en ese
sentido es una pena que se haya hecho yo
creo que ahora tal como va la energía se
están mirando otros muchos caminos por
ahí y no solamente digo las energías
renovables las conocidas no el viento
etcétera sino que es están ahora todas
las empresas están buscando nuevas
formas de energía Entonces no yo lo creo
que
fukushima habrá que poner la tierra y
taparla todo lo posible etcétera Pero
ahora se están buscando otras otras
energías también fíjate hay una cosa que
para mí es importante señalar hace 10
años cuando fue kusama cuando hablabas
de cuestiones digamos medioambientales y
vas diciendo Bueno pues esto es
ecológico salían corriendo porque
Entonces digamos con las nuevas
tecnologías todavía no había casos de
empresas que hubieran tenido éxito me
refiero Entonces en ese sentido desde
desde entonces sí que ha habido en
varias casos de empresas ecológicas
digamos con esta nueva tecnología que
están teniendo éxito y me refiero por
ejemplo y los más que estoy haciendo
cómo se llama billón todas estas hay una
serie de empresas que ahora están dando
muy buen resultado Entonces yo creo que
ahora precisamente por estas nuevas
tecnologías y ahora precisamente el
gobierno se puso a impulsar precisamente
estas nuevas tecnologías no
inmediatamente que en un principio
subvencionó el carbón sino de algún de
alguna forma más tarde no como ha dicho
Carmen muy bien incluso empresas
españolas de todos los países están
ahora siendo subvencionadas están
entrando Entonces yo creo que el camino
ahora va por las muchísimas nuevas
tecnologías que se están creando por
ejemplo en la teoría
y Carmen su opinión Cuál va a ser el
futuro entonces de Japón seguir
apostándole a la energía nuclear y a
raíz de lo que dice Florentino me surge
una pequeña pregunta sobre el papel de
esta empresa que controlaba la central
nuclear Qué tipo de condena o castigo
tuvo o qué se hizo en su momento después
del accidente hubo algún tipo de reclamo
por parte del gobierno Qué pasó con esta
empresa
bueno la empresa sigue operando es una
empresa muy grande como bien explicado a
Florentino tepco ellos han sido juzgados
el gobierno japonés junto con tepco han
tenido que indemnizar a la población
afectada a hacerse cargo de los residuos
hacerse caso de cargo del proceso de
descontaminación del proceso de
comisionar la central nuclear Que de
momento no hay planes de activar sino de
de comisionar es importante decir que
estos son procesos muy costosos no Y
entonces ha habido una negociación para
que para que el gobierno junto con tepo
ambos hiciesen cargo de la situación es
decir no ha sido solamente con la que ha
tenido que
indemnizar y a la que tenía que sufragar
los altos costes que esto ha derivado
tenga en cuenta que más de 50.000
personas de la región tuvieron que
evacuar no y abandonar sus hogares Y
perdieron sus medios de vida Aunque
algunos de ellos muy pocos han ido
regresando pero volver a levantar desde
cero un negocio volver a levantar desde
cero un hogar con una situación tan
crítica de población pues no es fácil no
para la ciudadanía japonesa Entonces el
gobierno japonés junto con Teco pero
sobre todo el gobierno japonés con los
impuestos de toda la nación han ido
sufragando estos costes me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa
Florentino las conclusiones lo que nos
deja esta esta situación allí en Japón
en fukushima y lo que puede venir para
este país una vez empiece el vertimiento
de estas aguas residuales al Pacífico
que hay que cruzar los dedos la verdad A
ver si sale bien Perdón que lo diga así
pero sí puede ser un experimento que a
lo mejor funcione y sirva de elección
para para otros escenarios posibles
porque no es una posibilidad Carmen
rápidamente su conclusión
bueno Yo diría que hay que plantearse un
poco Cómo utilizamos la energía y cuáles
son nuestras formas de vivir No si
hablamos de un de una sociedad
sostenible no sé si los residuos
nucleares solo va sostenible No
pues yo les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros habernos explicado
una realidad que vista desde América
Latina resulta muy lejana no solamente
porque el tema para analizar es una
coyuntura en Japón un país muy alejado
de la realidad latinoamericana sino
porque la misma realidad del uso de la
energía nuclear no es algo habitual acá
en América Latina entonces pues les
agradezco mucho por habernos puesto en
perspectiva esta situación y como esto
pues impacta en ese proceso de
transición energética que estamos
teniendo a nivel mundial Muchísimas
gracias por su tiempo y por haber estado
con nosotros es todo por hoy Muchas
gracias por su sintonía y el nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos haber
estado con nosotros la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y Luis Fernando Montes la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera siga con nosotros Pueden seguir
dejando los comentarios a través de las
redes sociales
[Música]